I have something funny though so when
you told your mom who loves to cook
Soulful food like soul food like that
you were going to be a vegan how'd that
go
over was she like wait what well first
of all she was like what are you talking
about like when I didn't want to eat the
the turkey at Thanksgiving yeah and and
the foods that that I normally ate they
were like in shock she was kind of like
she felt like I rejected her and I
understand cuz that was her way of
giving love you know like my son is
coming home I'm working all over she
spent a minute on thatkey she spent a
minute on that she C the greens but once
she saw I was for Real about it you know
the next year the next year then it was
like okay I got to start cooking some
vegetarian food for this guy and she she
did it and it wasn't that good at first
you know yeah but no that's like me
trying to bake with all the like healthy
sugars I'm like yeah you got to learn
how to you got to learn how to still the
chemistry of that yeah now let me say
because I know my mother's watching she
has improved and and and she is a she is
a very
good she's your m is going to whoop your
ass she's a very she is like I have
improved okay she's good she's really
good now do you cook do you like cooking
no I I don't cook at all like I mean I
don't think you could be judging other
people's
skills know what tastes good you know
what I'm saying I'm like look I was like
you know what this tastes like I didn't
cook it so I'll put it in my mouth I was
like are you a good Chef no okay
no
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home